[Music]
so
a um british mother
is now set to is a very happy story it's
now set to marry
a murderer
in a u.s jail who she's never met oh
that's that's romantic that's the
reality we need that is this energy here
nowadays is there anything about a
serial murderer that gets you like just
hot and bothered oh no um
what murder what did he do i'm bothered
not bothered you know someone say murder
somebody say
what's his body count oh my god isn't
that a thing right now where like girls
are really getting into it
uh now
it's always been a thing i don't know
there's always been a thing yeah what
the [ __ ] is going on a doughnut
so a lady's marrying a serial killer in
jail probably pen pal just a murderer oh
he's not yeah so it's a british mother
of four who is now set to get married um
to a person she's never met before are
they great pen pals yes okay how do you
meet someone how do you not meet someone
and then getting physically so uh it's
it's a pen pal
service that they do that it's like
so think about like tinder but you go on
this app to find pen pals uh pen pals
that are in prison how does the person
in prison have the app unless this homie
shits the phone out of his ass there it
is that's the system they have computers
don't they
i will go ask them
when when anthony because you make a lot
of promises no i think that they go like
oh man i'm [ __ ] missing her so much
yo homie let's get that let me get that
phone and this homie's like he's like
there you go thank you
that was a good blood sound effect
all right
so she's never met him in person and
he's currently in prison in the u.s
serving time for his part in a brutal
murder laura o'sullivan used an app
which helps connect prisoners with pen
pals which led to her connection with
terrell ravon rhys
82 year old yes clarification
there are people
who sign up to be pen pals for other
people in prison specifically
specifically like you know what i want
to do today yeah is talk to people in
prison you had a friend that would do
that absolutely not gina are you into
this would you call me gino oh okay am i
into it no
you're a bert swan and you're huge
you're genius
someone in prison they already knew him
before they went to jail so that makes
sense right because like you're like oh
i miss you how you been oh we're doing
good that makes more sense you know but
then like yeah if you don't know who
this person is like why there when you
have other things like facebook this
this is using an app to specifically
because you're looking specifically for
criminals or you can meet people on the
outside
yeah i don't know no wait man they might
be criminals
you
it's like a murder or something i don't
want to get involved with that no she
got four kids and she's trying to marry
a murderer y'all well he's not a
pedophile she's running out of options
matt you're a bright cider dude you're
mixing up too many things he could still
kill these kids you know what i mean you
don't have to like you know have
relations with them
you know chill chill
[Music]
that's off camera dog
that is so cool
so cool man but it always gets missed
we need a camera right here
you don't even know all the handshakes
we were giving on this side dude damn
that's so cool man
i like how these hats backwards and
we're talking about the written house
thing yesterday yeah dude
mickey ridden house call me that dude
[ __ ] out of that
so the 32 year old started corresponding
with recent october 2021 and said she
enjoyed reading the letters and poems he
sent her oh romantic that she was blown
away by his proposal over the phone
which involved some help from her mom
and sister who both support the
relationship
what laura's planning the wedding for
next year though it will have to be held
in the prison and the attendance list
will be limited to the couple
and one guest pretty much what do you
think his poem sounded like roses are
red i didn't do it
it
she's like
i'm blown away
is this a two-line poem this guy's in
prison prison right prison prison
because you know based off the stories
we heard from big herc
like people that are there are super
high level
so he could be working her ass and she
doesn't even know and then she's gonna
start being accomplice smuggling other
phones and her butt but what if he's
just in love
well can't can't you like he's getting
love in there oh yeah he is isn't it you
can you can sponsor people in prison so
that they get like more noodles or some
[ __ ] yeah the commissary that's a bad
example of an idol right if i sponsor
people in jail green kinder banging
[Music]
[Applause]
don't smell it
would you guys do if that was like your
sister
huh
i'm marrying my sister in jail
what the [ __ ] how did your brain go
there you asked me what would i so i'm
terrell right and my sister how did
everyone else take it
i took it the same way yeah their their
initial understands are my favorite the
other day
the other day there was a criminal and
then he goes yeah look at the picture
and then the criminal has a cop like
holding him and joe goes and he's a cop
i always look forward to their first
line
and then you have to question yourself
right like did i explain that wrong yeah
yeah did i [ __ ] up you think you're
[ __ ] crazy so confident
he's like
he's like i'm in prison
so back to bart's sister that he's gonna
marry
i'm done i'm not gonna do that that's
weird
i'm not married no sister man oh
i think love
he created this small created the
scenario stronger he's grown for it that
you should live for
love is the most strongest thing that
you should live for i agree
someone get that chatted right now or
die for murder strongest thing
you should live for i don't know it
doesn't phase me either that or tattoo
fear everyone i have friends in jail
i live for love it's not that big of a
deal you know it's like and there's
criminals all over are they on the app
finding pen pals no i have to ask them i
haven't written to them in like ages so
they're not i'm not being a good friend
right now but i don't like writing
letters unless it's a contract and i
have to [ __ ] mail it somewhere
she only likes signing your name
probably do you know the name of the app
by the way
pen pals
did you catch that no
that's very good yeah that's dope man
that's why you guys have successful
brands you know yeah that's why
that's so good um so reese who is 31 is
currently serving a jail sentence of up
to 40 years for second degree murder for
his part in the death of 19 year old
justin solomon in 2009 where he
contacted the deceased to sell him a car
but actually planned to rob him along
with another man oh it's not that bad
solomon was murdered in detroit michigan
when he arrived at the meeting spot and
another person appeared with an assault
rifle shooting him several times and
killing him
dude the person who pulled the trigger
was never convicted while reece was
arrested shortly after fleeing the scene
and jailed for murder in the second
degree i'd married this guy well because
he was just in the he was just a girl
but the guy who pulled the trigger i
would i would marry him why would you
marry this guy terrell cause it's just
it's just an unfortunate no he's not mad
he doesn't do he's no i'm just curious
no he's pissed um he just he just had a
rough life you know what i mean he just
didn't he wasn't that's where your mind
goes to i would've been like dude like
you sucked as a criminal you didn't even
[ __ ] get the money and you didn't get
away like i want i want someone okay i'm
not a woman but i look like one i'll be
like you read my mind yeah i'll be like
check it out
i can't tell the difference
i'll be like uncanny i like ambitious
ambitious and successful man you like
[ __ ] i like ambitious and successful
men you know like this is prime [ __ ]
right me it's ryan my [ __ ] right hello
i ain't gonna [ __ ] get with a guy
that failed
a [ __ ] heist i'm gonna get with the
guy that's high level yeah that's right
i [ __ ] up you don't you don't [ __ ]
with me but then the nurturing inside of
me as a woman comes in and i go but wait
you need you need my help what happened
what happened you had such a strong
argument but then but then i'm a girl so
i'm just trying to save him huh yeah i
gotta save him you're just switching
sounds like a female yeah
and then and then and then it's not that
we switch sides we look at everything
[ __ ] objective i like colleen being
like that
like
not bad and then i'm gonna be like and
then together we're gonna be a power
couple and then with my nurturing
i'm gonna fix him and he's gonna be a
great criminal one day so then you're
back on my side yeah so you would marry
him too
so laura laura said that laura said she
was impressed by her husband-to-be's
quote honesty and openness about his
criminal past saying he's a very
different man how is he gonna lie
what the [ __ ]
his poem rosa red i didn't do it do it
yeah yeah she's like oh it's a baikoo
you'll never lie to me
she described him as someone who was
young and stupid who now wishes he'd
made better choices that could be true a
good person i like that what happened to
her original husband with the four
children maybe it wasn't a husband yeah
maybe she never had a husband maybe she
adopted me it's judging different
inmates
she's trying to go up the ladder
petty crimes was the first guy she's
trying to get to the warden you know
what i mean all four children are
different trying to get the award now
i'm just you know it's all a scheme to
break out the original dad
we're scared she's working him it's the
new prisoner the lot twist
i like this movie six movies fifth try
all four tries is another kid
they were all conjugal visits that's the
name of the movie yeah conjugal visits
oh fifth try the longest oh
it's called miss
she shows up as a nerd too first but
after getting a makeover in jail she has
to start as a nerd she gets all hot
after the makeover in general i like it
misconception did you take her glasses
off and that's it
she is a criminal i thought she was a
nerd before instantly a five movie deal
because she did it so much dude i like
it i love it
[Music]
[Music]
you